there are allegations among the 13
charges against lying Republican
Congressman George Anthony devolder
Santos known to some as George Santos
known to some as Anthony Santos or
Anthony devolder or George devolder
there's all these permutations okay he
is accused of using campaign funds
embezzling campaign funds for personal
use like designer clothing
like with every
this applies to everyone
um allegations I'm sorry the charges are
allegations they aren't proof we will
wait and see what ultimately comes of
this but this truly seems like one of
the most immoral
unethical folks to be currently involved
in American elected politics